all right let's figure out the
destinations that we prefer for desean
watson where we would like to see him
traded if it comes to that here's the
trivia question that will determine the
first pick christopher deshawn watson
led the nfl in passing yards this season
before that who was the last afc south
quarterback to lead the nfl in passing
yards hmm wow okay
um
yup i'm just thinking here okay last i i
mean my mind really
wants to go to matt job
is that your answer
that is you know you're trying this on
the like i'm thinking about matt shaw
and then you wait and listen for the
horns uh i'm too good um we got it go
ahead you got the first pick um
historian okay historian historian
historian
well let's see here
okay
i want him to go to the san francisco
49ers that's what i'm rooting for that's
where i want to see it i don't know why
yeah
i mean i i'm
i'd love to see that quarterback play
with my buddy kyle shanahan i'd love to
see him in that offense
i you know i think their team is
phenomenal when healthy i mean we saw
how competitive they were when they were
the most banged up team in the history
of the sport
well i i that that's where i want to go
the san francisco 49ers who i think are
in the super bowl window i think more
than anything i'd love to see desean
watson matched up with shanahan in that
offense i think he would fit perfectly
i'm gonna pick that number one
hey fine if you're gonna play that game
then i want him to go to the vikings and
i want kirk cousins to go to the 49ers
and i want jimmy garoppolo to go to the
texans i want this three-team trade that
we have begun to design i want rick
spielman to be watching the show today
thinking hey those idiots 99 of the time
are one percent on to something today
i'm going to start making some phone
calls so i've got i've got desean watson
coming to minnesota and it is a i love
him not dave yeah that's what i was
gonna say thank you it is they love you
not today kurt
sorry deshawn's available the hell with
you we don't need you anymore
um
after that i think my next one's gonna
have to be the new england patriots yes
i'd love to see that combination
bill belichick desean watson his skill
set
he's gonna have knowledge of the offense
already that to me would be a huge
factor there because that offense we've
talked about it a lot it's very hard to
understand so they wouldn't have to
start back at square one you know they
could really start to go wait hey look
at all these things we got in this
office you can do some of the brady
stuff we had and then we could do some
stuff that you know we never thought we
could do with anybody and now we got you
and let's draw it up whoa we never did
that i would love to see him go in new
england and play with the patriots
all right my next choice is the place
where we think he wants to go but my
caveat is if he goes to miami
you've got to change the uniforms i
can't look at the current uniforms
anymore i can't look at them i love
the old ones and brian flores has said
himself he'd like to put the the team
back in the old ones it comes down to
stephen ross and what he wants to do and
there's a certain amount of pride in the
fact that these are the uniforms that we
created no
get rid of them put the old ones back on
the players and then i'm on board with
deshaun watson on the dolphins i i like
the unis what don't you like about them
what's
everything really i just don't i don't
like that goofy little stylized dolphin
the old dolphin that that's football
that's tradition and there's no reason
not to put and and the way that the
colors are and the block numbers and and
the it's just it's a it's a great great
look in the gray face mask i love
everything about the old uniforms and uh
so if they go back to the old uniforms
dolphins is my second pick okay all
right that's only a uniform related
draft here um uh no it's just it's a
fact i know i hear it's a factor okay i
get you i get you um
and after this i don't know where i want
to go here there's some interesting ones
i i mean i think for pure theatrics and
wanting to see it i don't know if it's
really a realistic team to think that it
can totally happen you know with the big
ben situation but the steelers i think
are the next team where if you just ask
me where i'd like to see him go or play
yeah i'd love to see him in the in the
you know black and yellow i think he'd
look cool in that uniform to your point
with the dolphins all right and
uh
yeah him mike tomlin chase claypool
deontay johnson some of the things they
have there afc north lamar jackson and
baker mayfield and joe burrow holy cow
batman that would be unbelievable
quarterbacks in one division uh that
would be my my last pick mike
and i'm torn now between the bears and
the browns because i'm fascinated by
the possibility of baker mayfield
playing for the texans deshaun watson
playing for the browns i'll go with the
bears the bears haven't had a franchise
quarterback since sid luck when they
thought they were going to get one in
jay cutler and yeah he threw for a lot
of yards they didn't win many games they
gave up a lot to get khalil mack and i
don't know that they even would be
interested in giving up the draft
capital necessary to get to sean watson
but uh matt nagy deshawn watson working
together i think that would be a great
combination and i think watson could be
what the bears fans have been waiting
for for decades at the quarterback
position yeah uh they would that that
city they might have a super bowl party
in the street if they got deshawn watson
they're
starving for it
uh
last i go on you know the regional
sports network there in chicago and do
some things every week
they've asked about deshaun watts in the
last two weeks do you think we could get
them anything that's possible do you
think there's a so they're they're dying
for a franchise superstar type
quarterback and you know as we talked
about there's a team that they're closer
to the top and the bottom and got a lot
of good pieces in place and i think
enough wide receivers and talent there
that he would look at it and go okay i
can make this work we got some potential
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports